ich habe meine zweiwöchige youtube-pause
hier zu Beginn des Jahres wirklich sehr
genossen ich war im Urlaub ich habe mir
Ruhe angetan ich habe gechillt ich habe
Sport gemacht ich habe viel mit Freunden
unternommen und jetzt
geht alles wieder den Bach runter
denn euer
lieblings-youtuber von hinten reagiert
tatsächlich heute zum ersten Mal nach
einem Jahr wieder auf hilf mir vom
nördie loser zum frischen Checker und
wie wir das natürlich immer machen
[Musik]
der Tisch ist auf jeden Fall in den
nächsten Wochen kaputt wir schauen uns
erstmal ein paar Kommentare an alle
Schauspieler in hilf mir haben in Oscar
in allen Kategorien verdient ich finde
es gut dass ihr weiterhin Sonne Gülle
bringt das Fahrrad war der beste
Schauspieler ganz ehrlich manchmal bin
ich froh dass es nur gespielt ist ich
sterbe vor Lachen ich habe noch nie so
krass das Bedürfnis gehabt Schuhe nach
jemanden zu schmeißen wie bei Pascal
einer der witzigsten Videos die ich
kenne dieser Moment wenn man jede Hilfe
Folge anschaut weil man hofft dass Luca
dabei ist das bin ich
ich das Wissen tatsächlich die wenigsten
kommen ja aus dem Assi TV Bereich habe
früher bei hilf mir quasi mit gegründet
Stress Pinocchio Fresse Alter das
Gesicht geblieben
ist los hallo hey
[Musik]
Pinocchio Fresse ist dir das Gesicht
stehen geblieben
[Musik]
hallo
bin ich hierbei Hilfe oder bei
UFC kaufte irgendwas gemacht geht sie
wirklich gut
mein Bruder oh das ist ihr Bruder
ey das sieht schon wieder mit viel zu
sehr nach Köln aus alles ne ey solche
Typen wie Pascal finde
große Fresse aber nichts dahinter der
hat doch los auf der Stirn stehen
[Musik]
ich habe Laser auf dich
wenn er mein Bruder noch einmal so dumm
anmacht dann sorge ich persönlich dafür
dass der hier fliegt sehr sehr selten
ey das doch nicht wahr dass das Giga
Center schon voll oft völlig besoffen
Körbe geworfen habe und ein
Tischtennisschläger auch mal
ja besser nicht weiter reden
okay das ist mein Bruder du kennst ihn
kein Stück okay
ihn kennen würdest
hey
also mal ganz kurz Erklärung das hier
ist der Pascal der arbeitet auf diesem
Autohof das hier ist die
Katja
katja ist allerdings auf jeden Fall die
Tochter vom Chef dieses Autohofs und
dementsprechend hat Katja als Tochter
vom Chef nicht mehr so Bock das Pascal
der arbeitet weil bei Sky den Bruder von
Katja angemacht hat ist es ziemlich
verwirrend ehrlich gesagt
schönen guten Tag
du bist immer witzig ich wollte mal
fragen ob die vielleicht auf die mäd
deine Freundinnen waren also was fragst
du mich für eine Scheiße Mann es geht
doch gar nichts an so warum hast du das
rumgehaft ja ich wollte es nur wissen
[Musik]
es war direkt wieder angreifen
für Digger Pascal hier aufführt habe ich
den Verdacht dass er zu Hause auch
ähnlich groß geworden ist mit viel
Aggression zumindest hat er überhaupt
kein Mittel mit Menschen zu reden er hat
gefühlt überhaupt kein Herz ganz und er
hat tatsächlich auch glaube ich eine
Abneigung gegenüber Fahrrädern
äh könnte der Andreas vielleicht noch
ein paar mehr Katzenaugen da einfach die
Katzenaugen
das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn
irgendwas gemacht ja
jetzt ist allerdings
Pascal in der Schuld von Andreas
weil Pascal sonst bestimmt gefeuert
geworden sein
Sprachen lernen
ja cool gerne
ach so das sind ja ist nicht so wichtig
eigentlich das sind so für meine Züge
muss ich dir mal erklären irgendwann
seine Züge
andreas hat meine Ansage nicht gesessen
oder hast du irgendwas auf den Ohren was
machst du hier schon wieder habt ihr
gesagt du sollst dich von den fern
halten
Besitzer ergreifen
die freut sich gerade an obwohl er
eigentlich nur was von ihr will und über
ihn an sie rankommen wird es ist eine
sehr versteckte Folge man könnte es mit
der Raketenwissenschaft heute
vergleichen nein Digger wir sind Freunde
kommst du und Pascal kommst Du nachher
dann zur Zugbrücke klar kein Problem ich
komme zu dir
coole das kenne ich da wohnt doch auch
diese Köln babos Geschichte gedreht wo
die in die Gang wollten und dann äh ich
schreibe mir hier die Abfahrtszeiten auf
die Richtung und die Zugnummer von den
Zügen
ich bin noch an mehreren Standorten aber
hier bin ich am liebsten was ist
passiert
um 15 Uhr 11 kommt er nach Wuppertal
regionale
Pascal ich habe gerade mal auf Pause
gedrückt wenn ich jetzt auf Play drücke
will ich dass du nett bist zum Andreas
gar nicht Alter was passiert für eine
Scheiße
auf oder was ja Fahrrad liegen
[Applaus]
Mann
ich hätte ich hätte eine Hobby für dich
heißt tatsächlich Shoppen im Shop
das ist so cool dass du dir Zeit für
meinen Bruder nimmst das hätte ich echt
niemals von dir gedacht so was hat denn
Andreas erzählt Andreas hat mir erzählt
wie viel Spaß ihr hattet und ich wusste
ja überhaupt gar nicht dass du dich auch
Bezüge interessierst ich meine wie kam
es denn dass du ein bisschen
cooler Typ ich würde mal sagen da hat
Pascal mächtig Schwein gehabt dass
Andreas wirklich die Haut rettet
[Musik]
mittlerweile so ein riesiges Bürogebäude
von 2018 perfekt sehe ich gerade
was ist das denn hast du einen Reifen
gefressen oder warum ist hier so dick
oder mit mir
[Musik]
mal an Mann was ist das für ein Outfit
eigentlich gehst du zum Sport
[Gelächter]
also
Pascal kann eigentlich gar nicht sagen
mit seinem Style was ist denn das
entweder es ist eine Unterhose hier raus
gut dass wir peinlich genug oder er
nutzten gelbes T-Shirt zum Layern bei
einer blauen Jacke es gibt ja kein
Problem
auf jeden Fall hallo was willst du denn
aussieht der Pascal fühlt sich natürlich
wieder große Checker aber ja auch
vom Checker zum Loser
also scheiß Kacke da wieder anders drauf
ne
Pascal nicht jeder steht auch auf so ein
ja gut das sind ja alles so Schauspieler
ne der heißt auch eigentlich gar nicht
Pascal jetzt nicht dass sie wieder Leute
zu gucken sich denken Luca hier
beleidigt die Leute und so das geht
niemals gegen die gespielte gegen die
Person die das spielt immer nur gegen
die gespielt Rolle also ne war halblang
oh mein Gott die haben hier eine Wii
stehen dicker das Ding ist 17 Jahre alt
ich habe Getränke bestellt oh mein Gott
die müssen gleich kommen
du weißt Bescheid okay
eure Getränke das ist tatsächlich wieder
findest du Baby Rest ist für dich stimmt
alles gut danke schön vielen Dank Baby
bitte nicht alles klar ja wir sehen uns
geile Schnitte seit wann trägst du
eigentlich diese Klamotten du läufst
doch sonst nicht so rum okay pass auf
pass auf pass auf erstmal
wenn nicht irgendwie Rede oder zur Seite
gucke
dann haben die Schnauze zu
halten
[Musik]
aber ich gehe trotzdem auf deine Frage
ein weil netter Kerl weißt du ja
ich brauche ab und zu mal neuen Style
verstehst du mal so die Hose bisschen
T-Shirt lang
fresh wenn man so ein bisschen rumläuft
und so
es reicht mit dem Helm ab vor denen
alkoholfreien Smoothies aber gut meine
Damen und Herren an der Stelle würde ich
mein erstes Mal hilf mir nach einem Jahr
tatsächlich an der Stelle auch beenden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann abonniert
meinen Kanal klickt auf die Glocke wenn
ihr weitere Videos nicht
ich kann mich da direkt bewerben als
Schauspieler